well in the immediate aftermath of the
election about 54% of businesses said
government wasn't paying enough
attention to their need says it started
off the brexit negotiations only about
24% said that they were happy with the
level of attention business was getting
and that's certainly the sentiment we
get from around the country in because
firms are telling us they really want
the economy they want business to be put
first and they don't always feel that's
the case and why do you think they feel
that way well I think during the
election campaign there was a sense that
business in the economy didn't feature
at all we had conversations about how it
was sort of absent and conspicuous by
its absence um but now the election is
over and the business of government is
starting to settle down we're starting
to see more engagement it's starting to
get more positive they're starting to be
more interaction on the details and the
practical issues that businesses really
care about that's got to be sustained
it's got to continue and it's got to
grow because of course there are a huge
number of complexities we have to iron
out but what would putting business
needs first look like what are the kind
of bellwethers that you'd be watching
for signs of progress well for Chamber
member businesses around the country
really it's answers to practical
questions will my goods be stopped in
customs do the standards I apply now
change after we leave the EU what about
the regulations who can I hire how long
can they stay in my business these are
sort of salt-of-the-earth practical
questions that I get from small
businesses medium-sized businesses and
indeed big multinationals alike and
every business regardless of sector is
focusing in on this stuff and that's why
we've prioritized it as well in fairness
though isn't that's not necessarily the
government's fault because there are two
sides in the negotiation and it very
much looks as if it's a European
Commission that's calling the shots in
terms of what is discussed and when well
we are very supportive of the UK
government in wanting to discuss the
future relationship in the future
trading relationship between the EU and
the UK as early as possible in the
process we're not happy about the fact
that that's been delayed for the
withdrawal talks to start first we'd
like to see that conversation start now
because it lets businesses begin to plan
it lets them put together investment
strategies and I think crucially it
gives them the confidence that both
sides are keen on reaching a reasonable
deal so we'd like to see those trade
talks start as soon as possible on this
and positives though from all this I
mean clearly businesses benefited from
the fall in the pound since the
referendum
albeit the founders rallied recently and
we are seeing for example a pickup in
business investment is the picture as
bleak as you're suggesting well we see
the economy as relatively flat in terms
of growth over the course of the next
year what about 1.5 percent for this
year 1.3 percent growth for the year to
come pretty anemic by anyone's standards
yes there are some bright spots in that
some of our exporters are doing great
business at the moment particularly
those who supply chain is entirely
sourced from within the UK they're
having a great time of it at the moment
but then there are others who of course
import first or who are in multi
national supply chains and they say that
sterling can cut both ways for them so
it's a mixed picture very definitely I
think if you want to change that if you
want to go from one point three percent
growth one point five percent growth
something better you have to go beyond
brexit and focus on some of the domestic
environment here in the UK as well our
politicians could spend all their time
talking about brexit but if you can't
get around on the roads you don't have a
mobile phone signal you can't get the
people you need you're not going to be
doing as much business as you otherwise
would and those practical things need to
be on the table after the election there
was a lot of concern about political
instability you remember still seeing
that and feeling that I think what our
businesses say is they want a workable
government getting down as a business of
governing as fast as possible and I
think that they've been encouraged by
what they've seen over the past few
weeks that the likelihood is that that's
going to be the case I think for them
what they say is a lot of what we need
doesn't need legislation a lot of our
priorities whether they be around roads
for example mobile phones you name it
businesses say government can help us
with some of these issues without
legislation so the parliamentary
gridlock isn't as big of a problem for
some of the real world business problems
as it is say for breakfast